this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia.edu good morning so good to see
that so many of you were able to get up
make it out on a Saturday for yet
another conference where we look at
probably one of the most important set
of issues facing those of us to do
public health or who are engaged in
health education this is a talk that has
a lot of modules I've discovered that in
a long life as many of you know i just
turned 65 I've come to understand a lot
about the way in which public addresses
like this are actually perceived by an
audience because I have been doing this
since an ear that predates PowerPoint
and really come to understand some of
the weaknesses of using electronic means
to present complex information that is
quite likely to be lost on an audience
that is not taking notes if I give you
50 PowerPoint slides in an hour
presentation many of which contain data
data that might be presented for example
and a correlation table an
eight-by-eight correlation table it has
an end a pearson correlation coefficient
and a p-value there a couple of thousand
pieces of information it will flash
before your eyes in about a minute and
the probability that you remember what
has been said is really rather minimal
human beings don't really have the
capacity to memorize that quickly and
short-term memory being what it is I
come to learning that the best thing to
do is not to make a presentation that is
really on the article that is splashed
upon the screen or it is spoken by the
speaker it is the think of a talk it's
just that there's something that is more
like an op-ed piece so I want you to
understand this is a talk which I want
to make a couple of points that are not
so much going to be supported by buying
a raising of an amazing array of numbers
but more by a couple of points today I
think all of us need to take with us as
we contemplate the future maybe you had
to get up early on the way over here so
you may or may not have had a chance to
read the newspaper the seat of
unemployment now stands at eight point
one percent and it's getting worse
people are just talking about the loss
of jobs there now beginning to talk
about a complete restructuring of the
American economy that restructuring has
particular salience for the talk I want
to give today it's going to focus on
issues of prisons jails re-entry parole
probation and public health this is a
tarp that also has a caveat attached to
it a warning to the listener one can
easily listen to what I'm saying in its
modular form and come away with a sense
that I'm stigmatizing a population that
lives in the
greatest imaginable precarity that one
could possibly concealer so long morning
that in talking about some of these
issues the purpose is not to increase
our already significant levels of fear
of crime and punishment but to talk
about the public health dimensions and
the need that all of us had to sort of
rethink in a conference that's focused
on cultural competency and sensitivity
to rethink some of our notions about how
the public healthy of the United States
is increasingly being driven by the
population of people who are doing time
in prisons and or J that's a big claim
to make and here's how I hope to back it
up why talking about prisons or jails
and confidence that's focused on health
education and on public healthy for the
easiest responses to note that prisons
and jails contribute to the
impoverishment of individuals and
communities and in the United States I
think it goes without saying health
status disease conditions are uniquely
linked to social economic status put
more simple terms with poorer you are
the greater the likelihood that you'll
be exposed to illness disease where the
conditions that will ultimately result
in the rather serious loss of your
health status so we focus on this
population because as they grow and as
they become an important component of
poor communities of color where some of
our most significant public health
problems are located part of what is
going to be required that we really
understand the nature of the phenomenon
that we're doing and the way in which
it's todd not just the public health but
to some rather complex social phenomena
and have a lot to do with education and
then have a lot to do with the economy
the statistics vary depending on how you
look at them and as another cabinet
number three I think it's important for
Americans to understand something that
we actually probably don't have enough
attention to even institutions of higher
learning like this we do not have a
national government with a national
minister of crime and punishment we have
56 each of which has a very different
set of laws governing how it treats
inmates how it runs its jails how it
structures its Department of Corrections
and how it even structure is the way in
which health care is delivered to those
populations are you aware of the fact
that the only population in the United
States that has a constitutional
guarantee of health care are inmates in
jails and prisons not you not me not
folks who work no we don't have that
constitutional guarantee but if you're
in the slammer while on one hand you
have lost many of your constitutional
rights the one that you retain there's
the one that says in order to avoid cool
and unusual punishment if you're ill you
have to be taken care of that's why the
state of California has a Department of
Corrections it's in receivership one of
the things that our class action suit
pointed out is that the over county of
california state prisons was
contributing to the ill health of the
inmates and as a consequence they took
the task of running the prison's away
from the governor and the state of
california and put it in the ends of a
sort of receivership institution that's
the importance that help plays in the
whole system of incarceration that we
have
country that's a good another way in
which health contributes to the nature
and functioning of that system men even
heard me talk on this subject subject
before so forgive me if I review some
things that you've heard from me in the
past depending on how you count it there
are 2 point 1 million people doing time
in federal jails or prisons if you add
to that the number of people on parole
or probation the photo sort of cycle in
and out of institutions and these
numbers will change depending on who
looks at them and how you classify the
status of an inmate the number goes to
7.3 million the enormous growth of the
prison population can be neatly excited
by the following statistic 2.1 million
now in 1970 was 200,000 what accounts
for the growth of public health issue
druggies one out of every four people
serving time in a jail right now one out
of her before is there because of a
substance abuse related effects nicest
talking about what's on the arrest you
let's look even further at surveys that
have been done of inmates doing time in
jails and prisons again depending on who
you look at and depending on how you
interpret the data may be as many as
eighty percent will self report a
problem with hard drugs that is to say
illicit substances alcohol that these
are problems that are particularly
present in poor communities of color
suggests that taking what for those of
us in medicine and health is a public
health problem and applying a criminal
justice solution has created a problem
that is so enormous that in these
increasingly hard times that we are
about to go through things are likely to
get so much worse what's the nature of
the of a problem that our point
the sheer fact that so many people are
locked up in previous parts I've given
these overarching statistics and I know
that what it does is create the
impression that we're talking about a
homogeneous population Oh sometimes I'll
break it down and point out that a
significant number of the folk were
doing time or there because they've
committed what we call victimless crimes
they are hurt anybody they committed
crimes against property but as I
suggested earlier part of what got them
there in the first place is their
involvement with the drug trade either
because they were selling because of
using because they weren't possession
for having but let's consider another
statistic that has also been used as a
way of sort of describing the nature of
the tragedy of having so many American
citizens locked up its the set of
statistics that described recidivism but
is to save the likelihood that you're
going to go back to the joint have to
have you been released once again
depending on how you convert the numbers
and it's important not to lump them all
together some estimates suggest that
seventy percent of all folk who are
released from prison are likely to go
back within three years present me well
in previous casa described the degree to
which the failure to have the capacity
to exercise the full powers of
citizenship once you are a convicted
felon accounts for a lot of this you
can't get a job in many states you can't
get along for your education and you
don't qualify for housing most of all to
leave prison and there are 600,000 of
them every year to do that I'm going to
wind up living in their own communities
and they're going to be doubling and
tripling up with their families but
that's only if their families aren't in
section 8 housing or are in public
housing because it has someone who has
let's focus on my
population here folks remember
conviction thats related to drug use in
this state if you have a drug-related
conviction you can't go back to live
with your family in public housing if
you do your whole family risks being
kicked out and as a consequence one of
the most significant risk factors for
homelessness in New York City as being a
male of color the previous felony
conviction on his record no qualified
for now see you don't qualify for loans
that will get you housing and you have a
difficult time getting a job what did i
just said have a difficult time getting
job this is march two thousand nine we
have eight point one percent
unemployment there is a significant dick
difference in the structure of
unemployment in the united states right
now there are avoiders nba's ghd's folks
like those of you in this audience who
are now out of work how well do you
think somebody who's done two bids of
the joint is going to compete with you
for the few jobs that remain in the
economy I'm very good is it and in a
society where at least for the moment
your health care benefits are uniquely
tied to whether or not you have a job a
population that already suffers higher
rates of morbidity and mortality from a
host of health related conditions
there's likely to find itself if it's
possible even more precarious shape but
the Civil ISM has two other dimensions
we worry about it because it typically
means that if you go back to the
community from which it came if you go
back to the joint it's because you
committed the crime that probably
involved
years so we have this dual problem here
which is why I raised the specter of
stigma there's okay you're back home
glad to see it please go take my stuff
please don't take myself but if you got
to use could you might not do it around
my school could you not like doing have
my kids yeah recidivism means that
you're probably likely to commit a crime
in neighborhoods where people are
already sorely bird by hybrids of
unemployment by the increasing threat of
a loss of their housing either because
they can't pay their mortgages or
because they are in the midst of
gentrification and the price of rent is
going up so high they can't save it but
the most important thing about
recidivism isn't so much what happens
when an inmate is in the community it's
the fact that when he goes back we
haven't really understood what that
means for the structure of the prison
population in the United States
three-fourths of jail inmates in the
united states have served a pirate
probation or incarceration saints near
your court twenty-four percent have
served three or more prior sentences to
incarceration three more than half of
all jail inmates have a colored criminal
justice stats at the time of arrest here
in standard the prison population in the
united states is a revolving door it's
the same folk they're growing in number
but with each additional inmate you're
not looking at somebody who's living in
too many instances an extremely toxic
environment where the things that
they're going to do to survive the toxic
environment are very likely to make them
quite problematic
citizens of the communities to which
they return they're also going to be
connected to networks of folk who
already understand the import of the
numbers I'm just cited which is dude
you've got no chance out there the way
they are going to survive is not to go
straight you need to be a better
criminal now when you look at surveys of
innings a significant number of first
offenders have enormously optimistic
outlook on the future I have learned my
lesson I know exactly what's going on
here I'm not doing this again until I
get out can't find a job we call it a
sixty percent of the folk we're doing
time and most jails and prisons in the
united states are for all intents and
purposes functionally illiterate they
may have finished school but they don't
have the skills necessary to qualify for
jobs so the notion that they're going to
get a job and to get out not only made
no sense in 2006 when the economy was in
much better shape and where unemployment
was harder now four-point-seven percent
in the world that we are facing today
with yesterday's release of unemployment
statistic that kind of optimism is
likely to lead to in my humble opinion
pressures on the psyche that are
imagining which leads me to my fourth
point about who's locked up let's be
clear than anybody who says to the tune
of eighty percent of our oil survey I'm
a problem with alcohol and drugs please
call a marital psychologist is telling
you that they are at the verities at the
parameters of a DSM for diagnosis for
chemical dependence which is the way of
saying one of the ways we manage the
closure of our public mental health
facilities is just just like the folks
up
roughly 16 to one fourth wall people who
are doing time in jails with prison in
the United States have have a diagnosis
that is absolutely consistent with
depression post-traumatic stress
disorder in many instances schizophrenia
that is being managed in part by the
illicit drugs that people use we're
talking about a population that not only
is suffering with a variety of degrees
of mental illness we're talking about a
population that is extremely unlikely to
get either drug treatment or treatment
for their mental illness while they're
in the joint despite having a
constitutional guarantee that such care
should be provided they stand where all
this goes that what were describing is a
situation in which we have created a
social dynamic that is feeding on itself
and its impoverishing individuals who
are caught up in this system but which
is also impoverishing our communities
some of you have seen the Brooklyn study
looking at million-dollar blocks I
mentioned this to some of you before a
million-dollar Blanc is one in which the
state is spending million dollars to
keep the residents of one city block in
this system of incarceration parole and
probation so money they've already used
for the care for their treatment for
their counseling is instead going to
create this system that continues to
build upon itself that continues to feed
upon itself and may I suggest has
conditions that actually creates madness
in addition to locking it up so I wanted
to focus on this talk interesting Lee
enough not on that have i scared you
enough by the way
I'm really good at this when I was a
picture lore I just love the apocalyptic
we're going to burn in hell the end of
the world has an ear you're going to
hope all year round here don't listen to
my voice because you will leave they're
depressed and how we want to take drugs
yourself zebras own feet it she doesn't
meet buckled anyone forgive me my
friends tomorrow I want to actually talk
about something that's pretty unusual
for somebody in public health acres in
line year in this month's issue of the
American Journal of Public Health make a
proposal that I found fascinating about
criminal epidemiology their work
criminologists and epidemiologists to
get together to sort of understand some
of a phenomenon that I've alluded to in
all these numbers and in all of this
speculation of just an identity saying
if there's a place where all of us join
together I think one of the most
interesting places is to look at the
process of recidivist and what it is we
do to manage it because I think
interestingly or not since we seem bound
to have a system where we're going to
increasingly put people of color in jail
we call the statistic that one out of
every three black men do time in jail in
his lifetime ok I know how we reverse
that especially at hard times when I
suspect a lot of people who are on the
margins who simply can't get a job or
going to add to commit more crimes just
to keep themselves alive just to keep
them self-supporting I think for every
rise every tenth of a point in
unemployment you're going to see a
significant rise in criminality and some
of the communities where all of us live
so the issue is not so much how do we
get people to understand that jails no
work we're too committed to punishing
criminals I think we really have to do
is look at what happens when folks get
out what do we do about the three
quarters who are likely to go back well
interestingly enough that becomes the
job of the folk more involved in parole
there make a quick distinction here
because I'm not sure that it's always
clear between probation and parole
probation is a sentence that is given by
a judge okay it's the judge who decide
how much time you're going to do in jail
and then what you're going to do if
you're not serving time / o on the other
hand is typically in most states managed
by a parole board which looks of your
case insides whether or not you're going
to get out now remember not everybody
gets parole the folks who don't get
parole or simply release you've served
your time and that would be great I
guess we're not for the fact that some
folks who get out really do need some
kind of supervision and the forms of
supervision that most enlightened
criminologist talk about looks much more
like social work than law enforcement
but what we have in this country is a
system of parole and parole officers
that's very tired in law enforcement in
my state parole officers carry guns
don't say that again and my state parole
officers carry guns they see their job
is really understanding the court as you
all gonna go back you're going to go
back because you're committing crimes in
the community I'm watching you I got my
eye on you and I expect at any given
moment and I don't like what you have to
say to me if I have you missed more than
to a point if that the court mandates
you're supposed to show up every week to
give me a urine and I don't get one
forget this presumption of innocence I
assume that that's a parole violation
you are going back yes significant
number of people were doing time in jail
had actually committed any crime what
they've done is violated the conditions
of their parole so the notion of the
parole officer is simply an extension of
the police someone who's there to guard
the safety of the community has its
logic we've heard about this it has its
logic and for a lot of the people who
get out please watch this dude now I
have an interesting family on the sunny
grandson of physicians that would
blogger who's the presiding judge of the
superior court in essex county in york
new jersey across the river with those
of you are from new york new jersey is
to stay on the inside of George
Washington
you can see it sometimes when you go to
the Hudson River yes Jersey over there
and 22 miles in is Newark the largest
city in the state of all type of capital
and the one that is amongst other things
sort of the epicenter for all out of the
state's crime and because of you HIV
also the epicenter of their HIV AIDS
epidemic my brother's been on the bench
that is the product presiding judge in
the criminal provision in the spirit of
court for 17 years sort of interesting
to visit is court because every once a
while somebody comes before them and
what you have looks a lot like a family
reunion son haven't seen you you've
reformed just sort of Judge they just
did time well are you doing all you know
who this rule that so I see you're back
yeah you say that to me the last time I
was here so I would you do this time on
messing around yes but what you do about
this I don't know judge sometimes I
think I'm more comfortable inside that I
am out sometimes I think I'm more
comfortable inside now but I'm inside I
belong I know my place out here damn
iphones hit your name written on it come
from this world is changing so last
judge i'm not always entirely sure i can
keep up and when I can't keep up I want
to do something to relax so I'm making
to take a drink or maybe it took or
snort and then while I feel the better I
also gets to be so judge I'm back
part of what happens in that kind of
scenario is for those of us in medicine
health education of public health the
question of wasn't there somebody there
when you got out who could it have a
conversation view about your life course
where you are going and what you were
going to do aren't there programs in the
community that actually could have
helped you out why is it that you
weren't connected to them or are we
happy that we have a brother in the
White House and we have every reason to
revile the Indians george bush was in
office but another one thing he did to
second chance ax worth billions of
dollars that have been directed at
healthy reintegrating inmates into
society recognizing it was 600,000
people getting out every year issues of
health care education housing and
employment had to be managed and that it
was a federal responsibility to help
States do that so these programs exist
and some of the ones that work best are
the ones that are directed at young
people developed first offenders who are
put into school situations either
bothering gb or when they get out and
who is a result of getting a high school
diploma or god help us a bachelor's
degree have or reduce by as much as
three quarters their likelihood that
they will go back in and that's
irrespective of whether or not they have
a job which is a way of saying that
educate someone who's in that precarity
and also you change their outlook on
life it's just like that very odd
statistic those of us in public health
site all the time we don't know how it
works but there's something about having
an education that improves now engine
health status and the likelihood that
you avoid a whole host
just that you learned about disease
there's just something about the
transporter power of Education which
brings a lot of you into this room today
but not only affects the health of the
general public that has a great deal to
do where the future pad that youth of
things are going to take the Urban
Institute which does an enormous amount
looking at the criminal justice system
in the United States continues to
propose that we think about re-educating
parole officers teaming them with people
in public health and in health education
as ways of doing the management or
footboard getting out so that their life
opportunities and chances how much more
likely to be improved the best but
sometimes was controversial all these
proposals is that we give young inmates
mentors at the point that they get out
there's something about coming from a
community and from a household where
there were no adults president in your
life and it suddenly putting someone who
cares about you there's a little bit
smarter than you in terms of what they
understand about the nature of life and
all of a sudden things change I said
something that understands a little bit
more about the nature of life one of my
dissertation students two years ago did
a fascinating study asking juvenile
offenders what was your perception of
the time that you would do for the crime
you committed interesting question isn't
it so for example young people convicted
of armed robbery often say things like I
shoot nobody then what are you knitting
bullets in the gun guess what the law
doesn't care armed robberies online you
used to go you straight to pee at
somebody that's armed robbery and so
instead of getting a slap on the wrist
and probation a little time
Juve you're doing six to ten kind of 6
to 10 s to do with how much you took
yeah there's a sense in which people
understand that there's the law out
there they know the Pope role also folks
you don't want to mess with but the
whole notion that there's a relationship
between crime and punishment that the
nature of the time is a lot to do with
the nature of the punishment Oh guess
what they're not really clear about that
not really clear about that and one of
the things that mentors get to do
there's not only guide people in terms
of setting realistic goals and
aspirations for the future they're the
ones forgive me because it sounds
paternalistic bread food well actually
sit on your lucky day and say good dude
dude not this way the other way there's
something about the nature that contact
that at least preliminary studies that
I've seen indicates that you can read
all through the life course of somebody
who's had that kind of contacting the
criminal justice system particularly if
it not only includes helping people stay
in job training programs Romanian school
or seek healthcare for conditions that
we are in a position to manage there's
something about making that kind of
relationship that's missing no current
way we manage parole I'm saying that the
public help them dimension the
educational damage and the conference
will retarded our public health and
education is one of the most important
changes that we can make an assistant
that is nothing less than China that is
throwing away lives and an unbelievably
rapid pace two hundred ninety percent
increase the number of people do on time
in jail in prison over the last 30 years
number despite we will increase in years
to come the notion that public health
folk criminologists and forgive me the
police and rural officers actually could
make common cause
together makes a lot of sense I'm
increasingly in meetings where I've come
to understand that the people who are in
charge of Corrections in many large
cities look exactly like the Pope that
they locked up their us they're black
there is bad who the would most
likely to be the darts who know the
folklore on the inside who runs all
right assistant folk who believe
themselves to be enlightened who loan
our community with the same passionate
video and see her job is literally
protecting it from a recurring cycle of
evil that they don't know how to stop
but they know the responsibility to
address we speak different languages we
tend to cast these guys as the bad guys
would have changed that discourse worth
we saw that we have more in common than
we imagine that what we're all
interested in is the health and safety
of the community and that there are more
things that we could do together to join
these two separate silos to create a
world in which the health of the pump
and the safety of the public are also
seeing his one my very modest proposal
we have to rethink the role of the
criminal justice system in American
society and then the annals of Public
Health we have to rethink what we're
going to do as folk were enlightened who
believe ourselves to be culturally
confident and we're concerned about the
health of the community if 100 every
three black men is going to have some
contact with the criminal justice system
we can't see our job is working with the
oven for the other two no because of
that one but this is all
you both stood up and you look healthy
okay and then they can hand you those
chairs and then the person to the
tablecloth include me with the
tablecloth on and the chairs can go down
it does anyone have a question for dr.
Foley love please come to this
microphone if you have a question and
okay DK Radcliffe
but I just what it says chocolate York
City Department Corrections thank you
very much like Penn Station the question
I'm going to ask you and it looks likely
coming to that understanding analysis
that I asked what do you think is one of
the major causes the crisis and I'm sure
see the crisis that's happened what do
you think is one of the major causes of
the crisis in black America I want to go
back to the very beginnings of my career
as a public health research many of you
know that i graduated from this
institution with a degree in higher and
adult education I've never taken a
public health course in my life that
I've been on the faculty of public
health from 19 years now and I've served
on a variety of Public Health Services
committee's has much to do with the fact
that I started out my work looking at
the war on drugs whether the war on
drugs actually represent the first crash
in the American economy where
unemployment rates in our communities
went through the roof and the drug man
was the employer or preference couldn't
get no job you can stand on the corner
as a watcher could stand on the corner
as a distributor and you made some money
first set of studies that my wife and I
did in San Francisco astound us we found
in public housing projects how many 13
and 14 rolls had become heads of
household because they were the ones
bringing in the money we were astounded
at the number of folk who had parents
who were addicted where the kids is a
way of sort of taken over the house
Sol's had to do it so to say hey take a
hit of this and see what happens well
what did that produce I suggest that
instead of recognizing that as a public
health crisis we decided that it was a
criminal justice issue so we continued
to increase the
these presence in our community now here
is where those of you who are purdy
biologists understand the whole issue
related to exposure the more cops in the
community the greater the likelihood
that if you do something stupid you're
going to get caught up in a sweep and
you're going to wind up in a joint I
have another talk that I like to give
just about what happens to somebody who
gets arrested put in a jail for more
than five days who's never charged who's
released and then what happens to the
rest of their lives and most states
employers have a right to ask have you
ever been arrested whether or not it
resulted in a conviction most part folk
can't take five days off their job and
still have the job when they come back
if you're away from your family for five
days what does that do to your
relationship I mean it goes on and on
and on it's over it's sort of a cascade
so I was describing is a cycle in which
the increased police presence in the
community was at one level justified
those of you who were around in this
city in the late 80s and early 90s
remember the level of violence that was
associated with crack cocaine use so all
of us don't like to admit them cops
pulled our ashes out of the fire in some
cases more than once but the fact still
remains with more than present in the
community it was inevitable that more of
us would be arrested once arrested as
I've tried to suggest in this talk we
begin a cycle that you can't escape once
a felon always for felling so the number
of folk who are right now serving time
in jail who've been there before should
tell you something about the nature of
how this snowball effect has caught up
more and more and more of our young men
let's be clear it ninety percent of the
folk doing time then jails and prison in
the United States or males females are
increasing in the numbers but right now
we're talking about heads of households
farmers we're really not present for
their families and most certainly for
their kids and as a consequence have
contributed to the deterioration of the
most important social structure the
community colors communities of car
have families and the presence of adult
males and females in the lives of kids
Washington Heights and 2000 boasted of a
really interesting statistic in any
given day in that year forty-five
percent of all the young men between the
ages of 19 and 29 for either in jail in
prison on probation or under the
supervision of the courts one of the
phenomena that a couple of people and
family planning like to track is the
early onset of sexual behavior in our
communities and the number of young
women who had babies the one to be
limited liberated from their family so
that they can get housing but we're also
kind of aware that this is a very
Darwinian phenomenon the we're
experiencing here these young men will
be around here in that law get it while
they're young make that baby let us not
become I'm talking about
african-americans and Latino so that's
not become Native Americans who by stead
to a forced migration and what can only
be described as ethnic cleansing had the
numbers reduced to a small fraction of
what was present on this continent at
the beginning of the 15th century now if
there's something going on here that is
the most disgusting psycho social
dynamics one could possibly imagine and
the fact that in this age we're now
beginning to see that this has a public
health dimension is for me at least a
source of hope because if we're tying
this to the costs of health care now
we're saying exactly how much health
care to broken families is a major
factor in the billions of dollars that
we spend on a variety of otherwise
preventable conditions we begin to see
that may be the most cost effective
solutions the problem with drugs and
crime isn't the continued to lock people
up and have a growth
prison population is to think about what
do we do to protect the health and the
sanity of families what one final note
that I absolutely forgive me just have
to add you know he's doing really well
in the stock market private corporations
that run prisons he might know where to
put your money I guarantee you
Corrections Corporation of America or CV
up those two they showed enormous growth
because as the economy starts to
deteriorate and we continue to resort to
criminal justice solutions on the fact
that in this country you have to be
arraigned and given a trial date within
30 days of your arrest means that as we
cut state and local budgets as we cut
the number of people who are parole
officers as we cut the personnel who are
engaged in the care and treatment of
inmates one of the things we're doing is
saying can't return this over to
corporation will run this type of
business and take this out of the hands
and reduce the headaches that are
associated with maintaining this stuff
those places are growing and they're
growing precisely because our fear of
crime is unfortunately ruining our
capacity to be rational about ways in
which other kinds of solutions those
that we are engaged in talking about
today are actually possible and may even
be more effective
i remember in two thousand i was in our
question for the spartanburg and he
spoke to us about discharge planning
policy that she works and that it was
not accepted now i made a part of the
part of his policy and it's a shame that
now in 2009 we still don't have a
discharge planning policy for the young
men and women who are leaving prison or
anything the gels and i remember that
time he informed us that the people who
were discharged from Rikers where to
stevenson heart and left there with
money or metal cart or something you
know it's a shame because we instead of
actually looking for the solution are
actually um actually addressing the
problem properly we keep serving around
the issue we meaning I don't even know
who is really responsible for ensuring
that these policy like these plans that
we have our actually implemented and
talking about the privatization of the
prisons one of the things that I'm
hitting it is the fact that we've got a
bigger problem than we have the money to
manage despite the fact that we
increased budget for cops continue to
try to build new jails in some states
the fact still remains we got more folks
coming in then we can manage which is
why so many states right now or under
federal investigation because there are
too many people in the joint and they're
not being managed properly it's not just
a question of the health care it's just
the overall management of a system
that's growing with unbelievable
rapidity people will tell you discharge
planning is a luxury now there are some
states recall this is not uniform
throughout the country there are some
states that have exemplary discharge
planning practices and policies South
Dakota
there are fewer people living in South
Dakota there in Manhattan so it's a
slightly more manageable problem they
also tend to have more money but right
now at a time when states are under a
constitutional mandate to balance their
budget with the state of New York
amongst 41 others having huge budget
deficits what you're describing is a
system that we know works but for which
we have no money and the major issue
isn't that people don't understand the
wisdom of this practice it's that what
everybody is concerned about more than
anything else talk to procure and
corrections and what will they tell you
their primary primary primary priority
is the safety and the security of what's
going on inside you put all your money
together to keep some problems with very
violent tendencies from completely
disrupting and creating situations that
are out of hand so the most important
part of managing a prison population
tends to be am I able to assure the
shape safety of my staff of my inmates
do not in the state of New York for
example we have no Department of Health
that directly works with the Department
of Corrections doctors who work in state
prison facilities are guests of the
warden and other staff and if the doctor
is there to see a prisoner an inmate
with HIV who absolutely has to have his
viral load checked and his meds given if
that thought comes for president in time
when the ward was really concerned about
whether or not he can control his inmate
population just what the doc doesn't get
in you see how complicated this all
become this is the classic onion the
more you want peel the layers the more
complicated it becomes it Nick and I
worked together we were both part of a
special projects for national
significant grant that went to the
fortune society to look at discharge
planning for people with HIV disease and
you're right it worked but guess what it
worked because we had federal grant
money and it was not sustainable which
is the problem with too much of what we
do in public
many of you are my student you heard me
say we don't have careers we have
projects and those projects are entirely
depending on who's got the money to pay
us because we fund this terrible habit
of wearing to eat on a regular basis and
wow we may work with the homeless we
don't want to be home this ourselves so
we've also discovered that your mind is
like an onion the more we ask the board
which holes and realizes how much work
you're late you are thank you let's see
the hands the preceding program was
brought to you by Teachers College
Columbia University please visit us
online at iTunes TC columbia edu